anh alo
anh
alo alo chào bạn
à à
ừ ừ
À hôm nay on hơi muộn Bởi vì tao ra mình
cũng chẳng biết tâm sự nói gì trong buổi
hôm nay ờ
Ô kìa
em gà hôm nay thì điểm về cái chủ đề hôm
nay mình định dậy thì ra thứ gì có thể
có vài bạn con tâm rồi mình thấy sự ra
nó khá là đơn giản thì mình dậy cho nếu
mà các bạn biết về skul rồi
sau
khi mà mình dậy các bạn về Apple rồi thì
cái
10 cái câu lệnh hôm nay mình sẽ dạy các
bạn thực nó lại rất là dễ Nó thống kê
thì ta dễ đến cái gì đó không ạ
nhưng mà đương nhiên là mình sẽ phân
tích các bạn là nên thống kê những cái
gì trong bộ hôm nay để các bạn dễ hình
dung về ngoại à a&e
ở ngoài ra thì
ở đây mình cho xem các bạn nha Thì thực
ra có cái tính năng xuất hóa đơn ấy thì
mình lại không định dạy các bạn Tại sao
bởi vì à ở đâu Mình mới sửa cái này rồi
không phải dạng PDF nữa mà xuất hóa đơn
này là xuất hóa đơn cùng email có thể
pdf này có thể Excel hoặc bất cứ gì khác
từ ra cái này nó lại khá dễ theo kiểu là
các bạn chỉ cần cha TP rồi kết hợp với
kiểu Excel hoặc pdf đó xảy ra các bạn
một cái thư viện gì đó ở các bạn chỉ cần
tải thư viện đấy về sau đó thì gọi đến
cái hàm của nó là được kiểu kiểu như này
cách chèn file và sau đó thì khai báo
đúng kiểu ngay nhưng sự ra được cái file
để mà các bạn đính kèm với cái email thế
này thì mình nghĩa là bởi vì nó đơn giản
quá và cũng nhiều cố đời chị là liên
quan thư viện nên là mình sẽ không đề
cập mình sẽ mình sẽ ghi ở đây để các bạn
muốn mò đấy các bạn hãy tự mò để là
à còn bắt đầu từ tuần sau thì mình sẽ
dạy các bạn phải gj và sẽ có một tí
Enrique nữa g Kali nó thư viện của
nó thư viện ra Swift đối ngoại thì nó sẽ
khiến nó hốt ra Swift nó nhanh hơn tiện
hơn cũng như là nó đã có khá nhiều thư
viện khó nhiều khá nhiều Gọi là Pocket
là cái gói khá nhiều cái kiểu na ná
giống kiểu cái này khá nhiều thư viện
đẹp mà hỗ trợ các bạn giả sử virus nặng
nó có cái thư viện đầy ra date Các bạn
thấy cô vào đây là sẽ nhà nên rất nhiều
chẳng hạn thế tương tự Thế có rất nhiều
cái nó ổn hơn khi nó trang web của các
bạn nó biến anh trong web kiểu anh nó
trải nghiệm người dùng có tốt hơn thay
vì pp họ thần hoàn toàn TP thần hoàn
toàn thì làm cái gì nó phải tải lại
Trang đúng không ạ Còn bây giờ bấm là nó
sẽ tự tự động mượt hơn nó không phải lại
ra nữa
anh ấy mình sẽ đề cập các bạn với Lee và
áo giáp
anh nói chung hàng cần như tất cả các
đội sau
mình sẽ dạy các bạn với Siro đi đấy
nghĩa là bây giờ giả sử bây giờ là
còn
cho là còn vài tuần nữa bạn ba bốn lần
nữa đến Tết
Anh hợp âm nấm ngon
Ừ ừ thế sau Tết âm tội hết sự cái dậy
rồi Có khi phải sau Tết là mình phải bảo
vệ luôn ý mày hết cái dậy rồi nhỉ Cho
mình sẽ thông báo với cái việc
bảo vệ đồ án sớm để cho các bạn chuẩn bị
mà thực ra là một tháng nữa thì các bạn
có khi hết thư sẽ xử cái đây mà làm rồi
em ạ bởi vì thay ca nếu mà làm xong toàn
bộ tính năng xem sửa xóa xong thì mình
chỉ cần làm mỗi giỏ hàng đặt hàng và
thống kê nữa có nghĩa là
mà chẳng cần thống kê giỏ hàng và quản
lý hóa đơn là có nhiều các bạn gần như
xong một cái được cái đồ án các bạn rồi
Bạn đương nhiên là có thể thêm những
tính năng phụ nữa đây tính năng mở rộng
nhưng ngoài ra các bạn hoàn toàn những
tính năng phụ khác tính năng mở rộng nhé
Anh Bình phụ nó thể là chỉnh sửa thông
tin cá nhân ở
em xem lại đơn đã đặt vân vân để những
tính năng phụ
ừ ừ
Ừ ok Nói chung là bây giờ mình sẽ bắt
đầu trả lời các câu hỏi nhé Thì hôm
trước có bạn hỏi các bạn có bạn rất tò
mò cái vụ là
Facebook dùng công nghệ gì thì ra bản
chất là
Ừ để mà biết được một cái công ty đạt
với công ty lớn rồi Công nghệ gì Các bạn
thì cảnh tra Google là xong là sửa
Facebook technologia use này sẽ là nó sẽ
dụng những công nghệ gì ở đây ở đây Cập
là đầu tiêu dùng ngôn
Cái ngôn ngữ
nói chung một công nghệ ở đây là sẽ bao
gồm khá nhiều cái là sử Đây là kiểu hệ
điều hành này rồi chạy máy ở như thế nào
là tao bây như nào ngôn ngữ gì nhưng cái
này như là hồi cũ thì phải bây giờ nó
không dùng cái rác nữa đấy
A và ngoài ra những cái cái gọi là phát
minhphát minh là không ai phát minh dùng
từ vẫn là dùng từ công nghệ thôi à Không
chỉ là công nghệ lõi của nó đi thì nó ra
à sử dụng Trí Tuệ Nhân Tạo này cho nhận
diện khuôn mặt này
Ừ cái này thì trí tuệ nhân tạo Nó để làm
gì chứ tuệ nhân tạo của nó ngoài việc là
để để mà kiểu hiển thị Đề xuất cho các
bạn cái trang chủ các bạn cái newfit các
bạn ấy thì hiện
để hiển thị một cách kiểu bài đăng có
vẹn chung là khá phù hợp với các bạn hơn
đấy tiếp theo là nhận diện khuôn mặt các
bạn biết được cái nhận diện khuôn mặt
này là là để mà kiểu đôi khi nó gợi ý
tác bạn vào một cái ảnh ở đó những ngoài
ra nó còn kiểu để nhận diện việc là ai
đó là kiểu giả mạnh Bạn hãy vân vân nữa
đấy nó mà công bố có toàn bộ thông tin
này cho ví dụ fp2 đại khái như thế này
có khi
việc tra do tội phạm dễ hơn
anh nói chung và Facebook hiểu bạn hơn
chính bạn nóng ạ Các bạn biết cái điều
đấy tiếp theo nữa là nó còn áp dụng thêm
nhiều công nghệ thì mà lại làm cái ảnh
thành khẩu nhiều kích cỡ để máy hiển thị
phù hợp cho em nhiều nhiều cái thiết bị
cái việc này nó càng tốt việc là ví dụ
là các bạn on trên điện thoại độ phân
giải anh không cần cao lắm em ạ nó khiến
cho kiểu việc tại ảnh đấy nó vẫn nhanh
vẫn mượt Còn nếu mà các bạn thon máy
tính anh phải HD ạ để nhìn phù hợp cái
này là khi mà các bạn đang một ảnh lên
dù chất lượng thế nào là cộng sự cố tách
ra thành nhiều kích cỡ để căn chỉnh sao
cho phù hợp
Ừ cái này là
Ừ thế giới à cái này là thực tế ảo à thế
nào thì tôi không biết nhưng tôi chẳng
biết phân tích Nghe Chú Đại khái thế để
đây đây là những cái mà kiểu nó đang
những cái công nghệ mà nó dùng công nghệ
lõi của nó rung như là tôi không ý tôi
không phải tôi sẽ Đề cập những cái mà
các bạn thì tra Google như thế mẹ ý tôi
là
để để để để mà phân tích xem là Facebook
rồi Công Nghệ gì ý Thật ra là bản thân
mình lập trình viên khi ở mình đến cái
ngưỡng nào đó mình cũng bắt hình dung
được cái thằng mà mình đang dùng nó áp
dụng những cái không phải công nghệ và
Kỹ thuật gì và từ kỹ thuật đấy thì nó sẽ
là công nghệ gì gia sử gia sửa nhá Ờ tôi
biết được là thằng Facebook nó dùng nấu
ask me
mà Tại sao tôi biết rồi đều đấy vì thứ
nhất hiển nhiên là nếu mà nó dùng thuần
swil thôi thì việc lưu lại toàn bộ dữ
liệu của hàng tỷ người dùng như thế và
sẽ rất là nặng mà nối do.doi vì nhau thì
vỡ mồm mẹ mình dùng để không ạ tự nhiên
nó cũng sẽ vừa rồi Các bạn thấy nó có
dùng máy của em nhưng mà nó dễ dùng Mai
quê ở một vài cái thôi chứ không phải là
nó dùng toàn bộ bằng mail thì chết chắc
là nó nó chết nó không Lát mình anh như
thế này Cái thứ nhất thứ hai là các bạn
nhớ về cái Facebook qua Facebook trước
khi mà thay đổi giao diện không ạ thì ra
Facebook trước khi thay đổi giao diện
loại loa rất là trận bây giờ nó lát mượt
hơn nha đấy mượt hơn so với ông à của
máy tính căng căng thì rau với ổn hơn tí
thì nó rất ngốn ram nữa ông ạ thì tại
sao nói nguồn ram như thế bởi vì đơn
giản thôi là nó đã dùng cái cái ngôn ngữ
lập trình mới của nó chỉ nhà rước
các bạn bé rồi nó là ngôn ngữ
ra Switch
tức là xử lý biến Forland tức là xử lý
trên chính máy người dùng nghĩa máy
người dùng kiểu ram ổn Nói chung là mấy
người dùng ngon đi thì loát nó sẽ giờ
nhanh và mượt và ngược lại là như thế
ngược lại là
xe máy người dùng mà quy thì anh như là
Lót cái Facebook của sẽ bị đơ Nếu mà nhớ
về cơ bản thì nó không ngoại mất công
Loan ở trên server
ở quần lót nữa rồi vất về cho người dùng
khiến cho kiểu không bị ảnh hưởng của
tốc độ mạng hay là server của nó sẽ bị
nhẹ bớt đi nhẹ bước công việc đi thế này
là nó giảm thiểu ở chỗ ông là máy mượt
thì loa Facebook mượt thế thôi do người
dùng nó tặng
ở đó Đang phải đánh đổi được đấy bởi vì
bởi vì hồi trước thì các bạn Lát một cái
phần 1trang rất là lâu rồi các bạn để ý
được k các bạn Đấy Minh rồi đôi khi nó
vẫn còn cái đường Linh đấy đừng Linh là
profile đ.tp ạ Thực ra nó hồi trước là
cốt thuần bằng ngôn ngữ p thành ra là
anh không không phải bữa sau mà khóa sau
mình sẽ Dậy ờ
Vì thế nên pp ở các bạn biết rồi pp là
khi mà nó xử lý xong hết Nó loạt được
hết thì nó mới nhìn thị ra cả cái trang
web thế nên là hàng ra nó bị rất nặng
một cái trang Các bạn thấy vào lót nó sẽ
rất nặng thế nó chuyển hết dần sang bạc
lót bằng ra switch
A và còn thêm một cái nữa Ok vừa rồi
mình nói qua về ngôn ngữ còn thêm cái gì
nữa mà mình cảm thấy là mình đoán được
đó Chính à
Khi bữa rồi Mình bảo là nó không nó dùng
nói quá đúng ạ thế nào dù nhé queo ở chỗ
nào dùng were phải trình cái chỗ gọi lại
cơ không biết được nó có dùng Apple để
phi cơ hay là dùng ngôn ngữ lập trình
của Sica nhưng mình tin là fg cơ đó là
liên quan việc là khi mà ờ ờ
bộ tem mình mình đang không đăng nhập
Facebook nên là mình tạm ví dụ cho anh
nhá Khi mà các bạn à
tố cáo bình luận
hoặc à
bình luận nói chung là đại khá là khi
các bạn đăng một cái gì đó đang ở đây ở
bao gồm cả bình luận này
tố cáo bình luận này
tố cáo bài đăng hay vân vân đó cho là
đang một cái gì đó
Đang bao chỉnh sửa gì đó tương tự thì nó
sẽ kích hoạt một cái gì đó sau đó ngay
lập tức
Vì thế nên là nó sẽ Khái niệm và chỉ cơ
mà bọn chị gọi là khi mà cái nào nó được
đẩy lên thì lập tức là sẽ có một cái đấy
được thực hiện ông ạ Tại sao tôi nói vụ
nó dụng chức ở đây 1 vì đôi khi là cái
bình luận khi bị xóa rồi cái cơ này vẫn
còn nên này ra trong nó rất lố bịch hiểu
Khi mà khi mà vào xem tự nhiên ở thấy
mất hết cả tố cáo mà giỡn rằng giả sử ở
bình luận vị xá rồi nhưng cái chi cơ vẫn
được kích hoạt rồi nên này ra là nó vẫn
in sơ vào trong cái bảng tố cáo bình
luận thôi luôn bình luận bị xóa nhé bởi
vì nó không áp dụng Apple cho à ràng
buộc khóa ngoại thằng thằng Facebook nó
không chơi dòng buộc đâu đó toàn áp dụng
cho hết là chi cơ đấy
ý nghĩa là về sau các bạn sẽ bắt về khái
niệm chị girl và Ivan và sự kiện là khi
cái gì xảy ra thì
cái gì xảy ra cái gì nó cũng sẽ xảy ra
cùng
chị sẽ xảy ra không đi
Sau đó mà cùng nghĩa ngay lập tức ví dụ
là sử Giả sử mình nói một cách dễ hình
dung hơn nhé thay vì các bạn dùng for
key để mà Bởi vì như mình nói là nó sẽ
không dùng đâu hết à Nó dùng nó equals
chúng mày queo là sửa là có có người
dùng này là sửa mình đi Chẳng hạn mình
mình đang năm 200 575 ở trên trang cá
nhân mình rồi đồng loại đấy Sau đó thì
nếu mà giờ sửa lại Wow thì đương nhiên
là các bạn sẽ nhớ là tất cả bài đăng đấy
sẽ phải có u ready là chính nhầm ID của
mình không ạ thì khi mà mình
Thế Hiển thị tất cả bài đăng của mình mà
mình sẽ phải roi bảng của các thứ sẽ bị
nặng nên nó sẽ chơi cổ Kiểu lâu với nhau
là 1 hoặc là ackworth nhưng mà không có
ra mù khói ngoại nhưng mà Chính vì không
có ràng buộc như thế khiến cho là khi mà
sau khi mà mình giả sử mình xóa trang cá
nhân mình đi cái toàn bộ những cái bài
của mình phải hiểu là xóa đóng ạ
chị sẽ phải hiểu là xóa phải xóa tay
đang đi thì cái cái cái để mà xóa bài
đăng này đi Thì bắt buộc mà Bởi vì không
có ràng buộc tự động rồi nên mình sẽ bắt
buộc một là can thiệp chị Google
à hay là cam Hiệp bằng thứ ba nó là một
thôi nó thích cơ kể theo cái even xóa
giá
Xóa Chắc là nhân mình đi và
còn thêm một cái nữa đó là các bạn để ý
đôi khi các bạn ấn vào một cái bình luận
hơn một bài đăng nào đó ở trên trang
trang chủ các bạn đúng ạ Các bạn hãy tự
nhiên là cái này không còn tồn tại nữa
Cái này đã bị xóa rồi cái đã bị gỡ rồi
các bạn bị thể về chưa mình thì thường
bị thường xuyên luôn đấy thì thì cái vụ
đấy nó liên quan đến dịch cơ đó là nó sẽ
có 2 bảng độc lập một bảng ở bảng bảng
và sửa bảng mình nọ vừa nói là bảng bài
đăng ở chim trắng cá nhân người Ngạn hoa
bài đoạn bảng 7 đang ở trên nhóm một
nhóm vào nói ạ
anh vào mua bảng newfit bằng nếu phía
kia là để lấy toàn bộ ID không phải ai
đi nữa mà lấy toàn bộ nội dung của bài
đăng kia luôn đấy Để ốp về ốp về cái cái
bảng như mít bởi vì nó nấu ếch với để
tôi thử vẽ Excel cho mấy ông dễ hình
dung hơn nha
à à
khi nãy nó nói trai thì sợ mày cũng
không hiểu lắm Nó xử có bài đăng bài
đăng trên trang cá nhân em ạ một tên bài
đăng Post không ạ sẽ có ai đi rồi con
tay là nội dung nội dung đi
như này sau đó đi thử cá ID này mình
không còn quan trọng nữa với nó nấu ếch
que thích nó là một cái cái ID được sinh
ra ngẫu nhiên có để tránh lặp lại thôi
chứ thực ra IDM không tự động tăng cơ
lại đi Số gì Số số gì đó kéo nó giống
kiểu Audi hơn bởi nói bên nấu ép của em
nó thế tiếp theo của bài bạn là bạn như
Tít
à à
thì nó sẽ không phải lấy theo post ID và
như này nếu mà làm như thế này thì nó là
axwell rồi Rất là sao Nghĩa à là sự Để
newfit xong rồi AD ạ ra sự ra sự dễ thị
thì đây giả sử là AD là ad một là của
tôi đi và bài đăng này mà đang một này
đây về gì á Sơn Tùng MTP
tất cả nhà Nếu mà chị đã giản như này
thì rõ ràng là lâu phí của tôi sẽ hiển
thị bài đăng MTP không ạ nhưng mà không
cái cái cái điều này nó sẽ dừng nhất là
nó do bạn như này nó sẽ nặn bởi bàn này
sẽ rất dài 3 ngày sẽ là lưu lại bài đăng
của tất cả tất cả bao gồm cả nhóm này cả
trang cá nhân đấy vợ nó sẽ rất là dài
nên khi mà roi Thằng này mày cho thằng
này thì vỡ mồm
nên nó sẽ không làm điểm này nó sẽ làm
là gì nó sẽ lưu lại luôn thông tin của
bài đăng
lưu lại luôn thông tin của chính cái bà
đang làm Muốn hiển thị lên ở trong thằng
ngu ra một sẽ hiển thị đầy đủ thông tin
mới đăng của thằng ngu dâu một nửa trong
này Đấy do mà khi mà các bạn bấm vào về
đăng thận chế bài đang là bị xóa xưởng
mất rồi như thế này khi các bạn bấm vào
xem chi tiết bài đăng bài đăng lên ờ ờ
bị xóa nhưng mà rõ ràng Các bạn thấy là
vừa ngồi trên trang chủ các bạn vẫn được
loa lên nó mới được đoán lên luôn ý
nghĩa nó mới lên luôn Đấy thậm chí là
các bạn Kéo xuống kéo mấy lần nhé tôi
còn bị dính á
Ok ông nghĩ ra mà nó có thể chưa kích
hoạt chỉ cơ sở để mà xóa thấy bà đang
này khỏi mi fit đúng không Không nó vẫn
sẽ giữ nguyên ở trên lưu ý là các bạn
luôn cơ tôi tả lại cho anh đi fit nó vẫn
còn ở đấy Xóa kết nó vẫn còn ở ở đấy
luôn
ý nghĩa là cái bạn với phim này độc lập
hoàn toàn so bài bài đang đến nay nó
không lưu ID của bài post bên này luôn
Tức tức là khi mà cái bài kể về đang bên
tốt mà bị xóa đi cái refit của vẫn còn
Cái Bè đang đấy mày không hình dung
A và đương nhiên là nó sẽ đưa lại thông
tin cũ của bà đang kia cơ là sự bài đăng
này đổi thành khác rồi nó Tùng núi ẩn ạ
thì cái cái nội dung này vẫn à MTP chẳng
hạn thế khi mà các bạn bấm vào xem chi
tiết thì nó mới hiển thị lại cái mới đấy
thế này tôi nghĩ là cái Tôi đoán được
thì cơ chế của nó làm nó sẽ áp dụng cho
Sica gửi thế khi có về đăng vào thì nó
sẽ luôn sẽ kiểm tra xem nó nó phù hợp
với lưu phí của ông nào và sẽ tự động
Insert vào chi phí của ông đấy thì ông
ấy sẽ hiển thị cái cái đấy lên Còn khi
bà đang bị xóa đi thì cái chi cơ nó
chích girl nó khác với cái rõ ràng buộc
nhé đó là kiểu xe chạy sau đó thôi và nó
chạy chỉ cần chạy một lần thôi nó không
có Nó không có kiểu hay chiều dòng 12
chiều khám chị ạ Insert song với này thì
nó sẽ có danh buộc lại và bên này Không
nó chỉ lấy thông tin từ máy này đổ sau
12 thôi Thế là hết để ạ Và khi thông tin
bên này Xóa đi mà không nói dịch girl để
mà xóa bên này thì cái bên này vẫn còn
ông ạ
Ừ nếu các bạn để ý kĩ thì các bạn sẽ
thấy nó khá khó chịu đúng ạ nhưng các
bạn sẽ phải hiểu tại sao nó như thế
thằng Facebook có phải áp dụng có chửa
đấy để chuyển cho khiến cho nó nó hiển
thị lý phết như phí được nhanh hơn để đỡ
phải rồi các thử thứ đúng ạ
a music các bạn sẽ luôn có bài có bao
nhiêu bài Lai trong ngày Kiểu gì nó sẽ
đổi dần dần sang bên này Đấy
tổ liên tục và đổ sang ở đây nó còn
không đổ theo một cái trình tự thời gian
nào cả nè đôi khi các bạn sẽ xem
em không đi fit có bạn sẽ không ở mất đi
cách nấu ếch với ao nó phải chơi cơ chế
nó sẽ lưu lại rất nhiều đây là nó sẽ
không mất đi
các bạn phải hiểu nó như thế anh ra là
nếu hồi trước là mình từng hồi rỡ mình
từng mò cái grab để mà lấy như phít của
của bản thân mình ấy chứ ra là của ai mà
mình có tóc em là nạn thì lấy được cái
nick phít ở ngọn ngồi nó dài kính không
kịp mình cứ nó nó có phân ra ngoài anh
em mình cứ lấy vậy thì mình cứ lấy tiếp
lấy tiếp với tiếp Nói chung vào kiểu
có bao nhiêu cái thông tin mà có thể
Ừ mình phù hợp với người nào là có nhiều
nó sẽ để sang lý fit mà mình sẽ lấy lấy
dẫn từ đấy Và thậm chí nó có lặp cơ nó
có lặp bởi vì liên quan việc cả thằng
này nó nó chỉnh sửa vậy như nó đầy lại
sang cái này nó có lắm đấy nhé
anh
nói chung là cơ chế này của thằng
Facebook vừa là yêu vừa là ngược yêu là
nó nhanh mà ngược các bạn sẽ thấy mẹ sẽ
Xe mạnh được cả bài đăng đã bị xóa cũng
như là như vợ rồi mình nói có lắp đúng ạ
đấy ngân hàng ra là
nó mình thấy thực ra là
Ừ nó mà áp dụng kiểu công nghệ kiểu dạng
giống như bây giờ thì nói thằng nào nhỉ
từ mạng xã hội là có sister à Twitter
Mình không dùng lắm đấy mình cũng không
rành Nhưng mà mình đã lướt qua một vài
lần bởi vì có vài vài bạn hot girl
thường hay đăng ảnh trên đấy hơn thì
mình thấy trên đấy không lập gì cả và có
vẻ bên bên nước ngoài thích dùng để truy
tơ hơn
Ừ Ok nói vừa rồi Khá dài rồi
vừa rồi là mình nói những cái nó hơi bị
chuyên sâu một tí gọi Vì ạ không phải là
khuya cái khóa này vẫn khóa cơ bản nhưng
mà bắt đầu từ buổi trưa buổi dậy phải
cái mở rộng này rồi thì mình nghĩ à Nên
Đề cập những cái nó hơi rộng rộng hơn để
mà gọi là có hướng Mở hơn cho các bạn
thì các bạn hình dung hơn đóng ngoặc
mình nói qua vừa rồi có thể các bạn
không hiểu còn nhưng mà các bạn sẽ biết
được qua là lập trình viên mình khi mà
sử dụng một công nghệ gì đó thì phải
đoán thử xem là thằng kia nó làm cái đấy
như thế nào để mà bắt trước hả em ạ hoa
để mà tránh xa được nữa để mà không nên
áp dụng vào trong trang của mình do Vân
đúng ạ a cho bạn càng đoán được như thế
thì về sau về sau kiểu gì đôi khi các
bạn vào công ty ở đó vài công ty nó sẽ
kiểu bảo các bạn làm cái đấy thì các bạn
đã từng nghĩ nó rồi đúng ạ Các bạn từng
tham khảo rồi rằng ạ à à
Có chứ Bây giờ các bạn dùng rất nhiều
cái trang web rất nhiều công nghệ rất
nhiều áp rồi nhưng mà các bạn
khi mà lập trình các bạn không đẩy ra ý
tưởng gì cả Không biết được mấy anh kia
làm gì thì ca hơi say không ạ phải học
hỏi phải gọi
Chỉ tiếc là
Vì sao các bạn kệ họ mình quý khách à
Mình không biết về bên CF đâu ạ
ờ ờ
Ừ cái chọn quận huyện này có bạn bạn là
bây giờ em muốn khi mà đăng ký đăng ký
điền thông tin cá nhân thì sẽ có vụ chọn
quận huyện thực ra thì cái mũi chọn quận
huyện này thì các bạn nên phải dùng
Switch Vậy sao Tại sao lại như thế bởi
vì ở đây các bạn dễ hình dung nhé
AE đăng ký để miễn phí
à à
nhà mình có chứ một tát đầy đúng
Ừ thì rõ ràng là các bạn nhớ về vụ là
thật sự là mình có
sẽ lấy các chân này
cô thường chọn quận huyện nó sẽ làm
trong sẽ lấy áo xinh sẽ là do sự là
Hà Nội được ạ
Các bạn thường ai thế là chọn à chọn
tỉnh thành phố
sau đó thì mới bắt đầu chọn quận là sau
đó thì sẽ bắt đầu chọn phường hay gì đó
đúng không ạ Tại sao lại như thế này
khá sửa mình cứ để Hồ Chí Minh như chợ
Ngạn không ạ
anh em mình chạy thử này
ừ ừ
à à
xe
tải ngay sau đó thì
chọn quả trở lại tại select option
Nếu giả sử đối với Hà Nội thì sẽ có kiểu
Hoàn Kiếm
hai bà trưng
sau đó thì kiểu quận gì nhé hà đôngnhà
nản
nhấn đấy là với Hà Nội không ạ này cho
chọn này về Hà Nội nhưng mà nếu bao giờ
sử mà
khi mình chọn Hồ Chí Minh thì cái này nó
còn đồng họ vì nó không làm đúng nó ạ
Mình sẽ còn thêm gì ở đây nữa quận 1cho
nào ạ ở quận 2 hai cái gì dấu vân vân
vân đúng không ạ
xe tải
em giả sử Nga chọn và sau đó mình chọn
sung dừa nhé không Bởi vì nếu mà như thế
này nhá Giả sử bây giờ mình có 64 tỉnh
thành ngọn mì hiển thị là có tất cả sáu
mươi từ có rất nhiều cuộn từng với 64
tỉnh hàng ấy thì chị hết ra đây vỡ mồm
người dùng sẽ chọn cái kia ốm luôn không
ạ Mình sẽ nở ra gì khi mà chọn Hà Nội
thì nó sẽ chỉ hiển thị quận của Hà Nội
không ạ Khi chọn Hồ Chí Minh để hiển thị
quản Hồ Chí Minh sẽ bản chất nó là gì nó
là gọi khái niệm gọi làm mát tinh các
bạn sẽ phải có em là khái niệm này mát
tinh và sẽ nối thằng này với thằng ngày
để không ạ
cho tất cả Sao mẹ là nói thằng Hà Nội
với tưởng với những ngày tháng này nó
nào giống mảng bản chất nó dùng mảnh
thôi ám chỉ được với Hà Nội thì sẽ gồm 3
gái con với Hồ Chí Minh để sự gồm hai
cái thằng ạ Đấy sẽ nối nối với nhau sẽ
dùng mở ra Swift để làm gì đấy thì cái
này thật ra không cần lấy áp dụng cao
siêu thư viện thì mấy mà thứ nhất ở các
bạn sẽ có một tệp dữ liệu có ngần nào
Cuộn vào ngày mày tỉnh hay cá thứ ở đây
thì ra hôi trước mình có lưu Vì vậy mình
có đừng có đánh sao mình cái không biết
được cái cái đấy thì Zalo lắm rồi chị
không biết được à Nó con à
Ê thằng con đúng không có thay đổi gì
không đi xem Đợi tí nhé em
Chị đánh dấu xạ sao
ê ê ê
à à
cài đặt ở minh tính
ừ ừ
à à
khi bé bạn của mình với bạn của mình
à Vì sao ạ
ở lại
ở Việt Nam data City
có ai nó sẽ có tỉnh thành phố này quận
huyện xã phường này vào nó sẽ làm cho
tải file data ở đây này
bộ 3 pha và file này sẽ lưu dạng kẹo vi
sinh mình sẽ đọc những cái pha này bị
dùng josh quyết về đọc những file này
màn chất nó sẽ là mã này sau đó thì
anh đứng ở đây có rất nhiều thông tin
nữa các bạn đôi khi không cần lấy nó Chị
ở lấy tên của thành phố thôi trở lại lại
sẽ có lần này thành phố đây mùng mấy mỗi
thành phố tỉnh thôi ông ạ ở đâu vừa quận
huyện còn nên người tỉnh thành phố này
ở đại khái như thế mình sẽ nối với nhau
các thử thử qua ba gà này sau đó mình sẽ
hiển thị ra được
thế hiển thị ra được hết ở đây mỗi khi
uống chọn một cái nó sẽ đỡ sơ sang một
cái
Ừ cái này chỉ Xuka thì
hoàn toàn các bạn làm được nhưng mà để
về sau các bạn làm ơi để mình nghĩ à
Chưa chưa cần thiết phải làm cái vụ đấy
thì thực ra là để người dùng đẹp trai nó
không tốn kém lắm
à Còn nếu các bạn vẫn muốn làm cái này
thì chắc à để khi mình dạy về bên gj
mình sẽ sẽ dạy các bạn về tất cả mấy cái
á sâu hơn mà bên g-suite bao gồm quản
Duy sinh đều ngoan ạ à à
a tiếp theo là mình xin phép chia sẻ về
bản chất với tune có rất nhiều bạn đã
từng hỏi mình chín bản thân mình đã từng
hỏi câu cũng bị đưa mình nghĩ là nó hơn
mùa xuân tí nhưng mà nghĩa ai từng trải
qua rồi lại từng vào khá nhiều người tự
hỏi mình rồi mình đừng hỏi thầy của mình
ngồi trước
Ừ anh biết hack Facebook không nhỉ
Ừ đúng có có có có đấy có câu là thầy
biết hay Facebook không cho nó Con mẹ
tôi hỏi cô ấy giờ ngu ngơ hồi hồi năm
nhất thôi với nhận ra kiểu hỏi Đồ ngu
xuẩn nhà tại sao là ngu xuẩn bởi vì thế
là thực Dạ nếu mà hack được một cái á
ở công ty mà có đến hàng tỷ người dùng
như thế nhớ sạc mình không ngồi đây nói
chuyện các bạn rồi ông ạ và chắc chắn sẽ
nhiều người sẽ không dám dùng nó nữa khi
mua thằng quen có gì hết được nó không ạ
ở đây cái thứ nhất thứ hai đó là
nhiều người hơi bị hiểu nhầm với khái
niệm về bản chất về cốt đến bây giờ các
bạn vẫn nghĩ rằng là cốt có thể hack
Ừ cái khái niệm hack thì nó là Lac nách
là
lách luật kiểu kiểu lách cái gì đó
Ừ thì xin thì nó mới là hack còn còn nếu
mà tu lý dùng tool đấy thì nó sẽ không
gọi là khó
a tool bản chất nó sẽ là gì Là cái gì
Các bạn làm được thì cái tô nó cũng làm
được đến là đấy thôi và
A và kệ tool bản chất nó sẽ tự động tự
động hơn trong việc làm cái đấy cho các
bạn ra sửa nhé Có bạn hôm trước hỏi này
à
Ừ bạn em để để ảnh chế độ mình tôi anh
có thể làm tool để xem được cái ảnh đấy
không
Xin chào hạ thế thiết thì đương nhiên là
anh thì mình thử hỏi lại vào đấy
Ừ ừ em có xem được ảnh này không đứng
nhiên là không rồi anh anh có hiểu câu
hỏi của em không bạn ấy chỉ để ảnh mình
tôi mà
Ừ ừ đúng Em không xem được cái ảnh đấy
đúng không Thì bây giờ cái tôn nói chị
hỗ trợ việc là nó tự động Xem ảnh hộ em
thôi họ tự động tải ảnh những cái ảnh mà
em xem được thôi
Ừ Thì nghĩa là em không xem được anh thì
đồng nghĩa cái tôn nó không xem rồi đấy
thế thôi anh ạ
Ừ
cái đấy là quan điểm đơn giản về việc tu
nó như thế nào ra sự giả sử như là bây
giờ nặn các bạn nghĩ thế thì thế thì
tung chẳng để làm gì cả ra sẽ sai Các
bạn thấy bản chất là cái gì cần nên tự
động chuyển hình giả sử như là các bạn
chia tay người yêu em ạ Các bạn yêu
người yêu trong năm từ
Ừ từ 2 2010 đến bây giờ
ý là 12 năm để nhận đó thì y không ạ Các
bạn muốn xóa toàn bộ những anh trong
phạm Khoảng Đời ra đấy thôi không muốn
xóa tất cả ảnh đấy hoặc là muốn kỹ hôn
đấy Xóa ảnh nào mà bạn đấy đã từng thật
tương tác mình cái ảnh thì thôi ạ hoặc
có ảnh nào đã tấn tác mà để may mà May
mà có vũ tát này ạ Đấy ảnh tương tác bạn
đấy thì xóa
ông ngồi xoa tay cái đoạn đấy vỡ mồm
nhiều người dễ bảo ở khuyên ông là thôi
tạo Sư nick mới đi không ạ nhưng mà
không cũng không muốn tạo lính mới ông
tạ mít mới xong thằng khác nhìn vào
trang cá nhân của ông thấy mới lập nick
nó nó lại nghĩ ông mà thằng trẻ trâu đấy
chẳng hạn thế
à Xong rồi
ạ Bây giờ làm thế nào Hòa có đôi khi
không phải xóa mấy ông chỉ muốn đổi hết
kệ toàn bộ những cái bài đăng đấy Ảnh
đấy hành chế độ mình tôi để nó sẽ em này
năm năm năm
sau xem lại để ân hận hoặc Thấy Vui thỏa
mãn và rơm rồi không biết được nhưng lại
khá như thế thì làm như thế nào Ông ngồi
rửa tay cái đấy Không thể đúng ạ nhưng
mà ông vẫn làm được điều đấy là ông vẫn
có thể
anh xóa hoặc là chuyện nón chế độ mình
tôi Trầm của nó quá nhiều thì tôn nó sẽ
can thiệp được kiểu đấy
em nói chuyện giản thế thôi không ạ ngắm
chỉ tung mà bạn chất nó sẽ tự động làm
được những cái thứ mà ông có thể làm chứ
không phải là làm những thứ mà không thể
làm Nếu mà Ngoài ra thì vẫn có một vài
cái gọi lách giống như Điển hình như là
tôi từng bảo mấy ông già sự là ông lên
nick này
Mà tại sao nó luôn thì chị
Mà tại sao nó lưu lại đường link này nhé
khi
bé nhưng mà giả sử như thế này ảnh này
đấy mấy ông thấy là nó không cho ta nói
chỉ có xem xem toàn bộ ảnh nó bình
thường mà sẽ nó sẽ cho tay để tôi cho
vào một cái vào một cái khác thì cũng
xem nhé
đi chợ đi đăng nhập
họ Đậu gì tôi phải theo dõi gái xinh mời
ông đều biết rồi Có gì mà lộn
à à
ở bên này cho làm nhỉ
Ừ Tôi muốn xem ảnh rồi
anh nghe con dâu Tài
cho đến nay không có tải
ở bên này xe tải cho tải nó sẽ anh chị
ra kiểu như thế này con à Không cho tài
nó sẽ chỉ ra như thế này
à à
Ừ mình sinh năm 1978 mấy cái gì
ý kiến mail mình à mẹ gọi từ thời cấp 1
mình nghĩ đến rồi Hồi nãy có bộ phim
trên Disney ở czech Long
Ừ đấy thì
thì các bạn thấy là nó cho tải nó sẽ chị
ta ngay bấm ở đây đã lập tức cả tại được
cái ảnh có độ dung lượng này luôn như là
nếu mà không cho tải thì nó sẽ hiển thị
ra như thế này để xem kích cỡ lớn nhất
là gì thôi như này nhưng mà các bạn học
lập trình rồi và mình đã từng nó rồi Cái
gì mà các bạn nhìn được thì các bạn hoàn
toàn thể lấy được để tải được các bạn sẽ
ăn nice pics cửa mở như này đây ngọn sau
đó thì ấn vào đây chọn đây nó sẽ ra được
cái anh ấy thôi Đấy cái ảnh nào hết bạn
chỉ cần tải về đó xong không ạ thằng
click thì chắc là nó không không nghị Cứ
kệ vụ này Ừ kệ bộ máy nó không có thực
ra là nó khó mà Thể Ngăn Được cái vụ này
như mình đã nói nó kiểu thì chị lên nữa
Cùng lắm là cũng lắm mà nó thêm logo của
đây thôi chứ nó mua khi là nó dùng thẻ
inmates hoa cà backgroud gì gì đó thì
chị lên rồi Rất khó để lấy
nó bảo nó không nó không chơi trò cắp
Ảnh này hình từng nói nhỏ một để mà để
làm gì cả đấy
Ừ
nó để khám phá mình nghỉ chưa gặp trang
web là kiểu như thế
Ừ nhưng mà vỡ trong trang này thì mình
mắc được như thế đúng ạ Mình lách được
như thế này thì cái việc lách này nó
không tính là khách lắm Cho dù đúng là
người dùng có cài đặt rồi những cái này
cái kiểu kiểu dạng là về bản thân thì
các bạn vẫn có thể xem được nó A vẫn có
thể xem được nó thì vẫn thể lấy được nó
trừ khi mà người dùng phát đi rồi mà các
bạn vẫn lấy rồi nó hoặc người dùng ẩn ý
rồi các bạn vẫn lấy được nó thì cái đấy
nó cả hack mà cái đấy mới là sai mình
cài đấy mình kiểu
Ừ ông làm được thì thì cái đấy là về lỗi
bảo mật
Ừ Ok
thôi tiếp nhé trả lời nốt mấy câu xong
rồi Bộ hôm nay thì ta dạy qua mấy anh
kia chắc là cũng hơn tiền thôi Mấy buổi
hôm trước tặng 2 tiền nhiều quá
ờ ờ thế đi học Bạn này bạn gái mà để hỏi
là
Em định kiến khi mà con gái học công
nghệ thông tin
ờ ờ
vì mình không biết bạn đấy chắc là có
thể do chính bố mẹ luôn hoặc bạn bè định
kiến gì nghe Định Kiến Huy tiêu cực quá
nhưng mà chắc là kiểu người ta có thể
khuyên bạn đấy là học ngành này khó lắm
học ngày này kiểu
ờ ờ không không hẳn là phù hợp với con
gái lắm được cả là nó dễ bị mụn này già
đi là tóc bạc sớm mà vẫn mấy ông xem ảnh
cô còn lại rõ cái gì à
em ngồi đau lưng này Nói chung là bệnh
đúng không ạ Ngoài ra thì còn là gì nữa
Nó khá là căng não cậu bởi con trai thì
về các bạn thì mình thấy con trai vẫn
Thiên là lâu gic Tính toán kiểu mấy cái
này hơn và chịu khó ngồi được máy tính
hơn con gái ngồi một lúc thì sẽ bị đau
đầu và người Vân bây do thể chất nữa
thế
nhưng nhưng mà cái đấy người ta chỉ
khuyên thôi còn mình nghĩa là thực ra à
là khá nhiều Điền hình méo ở đây tôi
nghĩa mấy ông mà lại đây nhiều ông sẽ
ngưỡng mộ thì thấy con cái học kinh
nghiệm công nghệ thông tin hơn là kiểu
chê kẹo voi con gái có niềm tin thì biết
cái gì không không Khi mà kiểu nghe bạn
gái là là dân IP các bạn sẽ nhiều ơi bạn
ấy chắc phải giỏi lắm anh tưởng như thế
à mình mình nghe thế xong mình sẽ ngưỡng
mộ mấy bạn gái đấy hôn đấy em mình không
có định tiền đi cả
anh nói chung là cái này là có thể trong
môi trường bạn đấy hả bạn đấy tự đi
nhưng mà về các bạn thì mình từng nói
tới buổi hôm trước thôi đó là các bạn
nên kiểu
ờ ờ các bạn lên kiểu có cái nhìn khác và
nếu giờ sửa có bị định kiến thật thì các
bạn cũng phải phải sống quen với việc là
sẽ có người này người kia nói
Ừ Miễn là mình làm đúng cải lương tâm
mình mà mình cảm thấy mình ở gù vàng hết
sức mình cho cái cái này thì nói lại
liên quan đến tâm sự một tí bởi vì thời
ra câu hỏi tâm sự mà đó là
thì các bạn hồi hồi trước mình nghe
người câu đó là
cho mình đôi khi mình sống cả đời của
mình để mà cố làm hài lòng mọi người
Ừ rồi về giao mình mới nhận ra một điều
đó là một người thời ra số người quan
tâm mấy ông ấy nói thẳng lại ý sao
anh kể cả bạn bè mấy ông luôn bạn bè mấy
ông thực trạng có công việc cầu mua quan
tâm riêng của họ cuộc sống riêng của họ
cái sự lo lắng Nói chung là đầy đủ thứ
mà bọn họ phải lo rồi bọn họ có thể có
thể kiểu thường hay đi chơi ông ấy
thường hay hỏi han đấy và biết được tính
cách mấy ông ấy thực là họ không quan
tâm ông
anh đến mức độ đấy đâu
từ trước khi nó bị rảnh mà chọn cái vì
là
à Nhờ những thằng như thấy kệ nó ngoại
nhà em chị ở cuộc sống này ông phải sống
về cơ bản là cho chính ông thôi ông mạnh
kiểu cứ để ý xem thằng kia sẽ nghĩ gì về
ông ấy về sau nhận ra là
ông làm bất cứ cái gì nó cũng sẽ nó cũng
sẽ có thể nói bảo anh sợ ông sẽ không
hạnh phúc khi mà sống theo cái định kiến
hay là suy nghĩ người khác không ạ sống
hơn chính mình thôi nói thế nó cũng hơi
bị
Anh hơi bị cá nhân và hơi bị Ích kỷ một
tí
anh Bởi vì sao Bởi vì thực ra tính của
mình lại
Em
nghĩ là mình cũng phải lên sống thêm cái
tiêu chuẩn của cộng đồng chứ không phải
ở kiểu có nhiều người là sống thì kệ
luôn tất cả mọi người Tao cứ làm việc
của tao tao kệ kệ mọi người miễn là xong
việc của tao
có lẽ tao hạnh phúc truyền hình giống
như bây giờ dịch bệnh ở nạn Mấy bạn vẫn
thì chơi thôi vẫn thấy hơi sai sai Vì từ
đấy Kiểu gì thế các bạn vẫn check in cái
thư thứ
nhờ tại đại khái nó là như thế đó là
kiểu các bạn phải cân đối giữa việc là
các bạn sống cho chị Thúy mình ạ Cũng
không không nên kệ
em không đáng kể nữa không nên quan tâm
quá nhiều vào người khác nói gì về mình
Anh bình thường ai bảo đây nó sống theo
lương tâm mình thôi Ừ khi nào chuẩn nhất
xuất hiện sống theo lương tâm
Ừ cái gì mình thấy đúng phù hợp thì mình
cứ làm không ạ
nhà
mình có ghi chú ở đây Các bạn nhớ đi
mail Khi mà mình thông báo mà thông báo
vụ bảo vệ đoán nhá Bởi vì không phải bảo
vệ đồ án mà làm đồ ăn hay này bởi vì
mình không không nhắn tin qua Facebook
các bạn được mình nhất là nhắn tin người
nó quá nó quá thủ công mà tôi lại rất
ngại vụ làm tôn lên Facebook bây giờ bị
tôi nói ở bây làm tôm Facebook nó dậy
chặn dễ ăn thịt bò em nick tội mấy lần
ăn thịt boise bay hết rồi Ngày nào tôi
sẽ không làm tôn Facebook nữa
anh nghe vừa Tôi có cái mail tất cả các
bạn đăng ký làm đồ ăn hay nhưng mấy ông
đã từng đăng ký làm đồ bán rồi thì mấy
ông Nếu đi mail và nhắn tin tôi có
discord vậy mà tôi cho vào nhóm nhóm
Ừ nếu không làm gì nếu mất cứ đợi không
ạ vợ chẳng mất cái gì cả à
a tiếp theo của bạn hỏi về api toàn bộ
những cái thông tin liên quan về api
này thì mình sẽ mình sẽ đề cập ở trong
khóa sau mình khóa này mình không dạy
các bạn với bia có thử được
à à tức là có nhắc hoa Khi mà mình sẽ
nói về A ráp thành trào mình sẽ nói qua
thôi ở có thể mình sẽ bỏ qua khi mình sẽ
giấc nhưng mà chuyên sâu hơn để mà làm
một cái bia Chuẩn Vân mình sẽ đề cập ở ổ
khóa sao rồi Ổn nhất tiếp theo câu cuối
anh hả
cách làm bài tập Toán chịu mà ông hỏi
với tôi về tài liệu gì mấy ông cha của
nhanh hơn đấy nếu hỏi tôi từ khóa này
còn đưa
ờ ờ
anh Em không rành TP nhưng học luôn
razzil có được không Thực ra cái này
nghe coi em thức nó hơi bị sai này bởi
vì à Thấy nhớ lo nó Facebook vpp của VP
nên kiểu gì phải học TP và phải biết pp
phải biết VP ở đây là phải biết đầy đủ
Vespa có thể làm được những gì Và và
phải làm được tương tột thương nối ppp
đã mấy nhảy nhảy vào nó và đưa ra có là
các bạn cũng không nên nhảy luôn là một
cả Vương Quốc Bởi vì thức ăn Nếu các bạn
nhảy và luôn nó quá bị rậm và vì nó quá
rộng nên các bạn chẳng hiểu cái gì cả
Ê hồi mà mình học từ đầu đến từ cơ bản
cho đến mô hình cho mới đến fan gốc mình
còn thấy mông lưng vì trò đùa thế này ra
bây giờ mà bạn mới biết một tí Tết đây ạ
Bạn này hỏi thế có thể mới học 12 tháng
À mà bạn ấy chỉ mới viết quá
các hoạt động chính là bạn đấy mới biết
qua ngôn ngữ này tưởng là cụ phát thôi
mà bạn nghĩ rằng Trung Quốc thì không có
gì cả
A Gọi nhạc
ạ Bây giờ gọi là mới tất mới cắt bò mình
tắt bò mà đã áo
kiểu đi xe máy còn đây có phải đi xe máy
nữa để phóng tên lửa rồi
vì farewell về cơ bản Facebook rất khó
Bây giờ ông nào khẳng định có thể làm
chủ thành đạo nhưng nói việc là nhảy vào
khi mà bình còn năng lơ mơ như thế họ sẽ
bị cậu ra nặng khó
cho nên là lời khuyên là vẫn vậy biết
đấy đủ sống như học xong quá này tôi mới
dám dậy mấy ông nhà báo Mở mô hình này
sau đó mình nhảy liền cái cuối mà em
Trung Quốc này thì nó không mực mới kiểu
mới gọi là dễ dễ hiểu hơn tí về sao mình
dậy rare các bạn sẽ thấy
300 mình không có khóa gì hết nào độc
lập đâu mình dậy ra Speed rồi mà chỉ
chạy ra sức và mức tương đối thôi
em có tuần sau từ tuần sau mình sẽ dạy
các bạn với Lee đấy
Ừ ok Nói chung là đại khá như thế á mà
có hai cái này cho để cuối bộ nhớ Nhắc
tôi tôi chia sẻ nhé Còn bây giờ mình sẽ
dạy các bạn về
ờ ờ thống kê thống kê
ở đầu tiên và bên admin này à
khi đăng nhập vào đi ngoại
cô gái này copy cái này xuống đây để này
chồng cũng được
khi nghe xong
ờ ờ
anh xem Hóa đơn đã
có hóa đơn hôm trước có hai đơn như thế
này
Ờ thì đầu tiên là các bạn muốn vào cái
trang đầu tiên như thế này trang đầu
tiên Trang mới vào ấy thường là sẽ hiển
thị luôn thống kê nó hợp lý hơn
nhà mình chuyên TP lẫn cả ra Swift theo
kiểu ở mức tương đối thôi mình Thiên này
bác en hơn theo kiểu là B nasware Hôn
mình sẽ dạy các bạn về lại TP reserved
đi chuyến sau về ép Gao mình đã dậy một
cách tương đối rồi đấy ạ
trà dậy xong khóa sau như mình nói chậm
vợ hết Sư các em à giận sẽ thỉnh thoảng
để mà nitrite là cốc thôi à
ừ ừ
khi bé bị sự thống kê ở đây thôi ta Các
bạn thấy hơi ít thông tin để có thể
thống kê đúng không ạ
em nhận đấy ít thông tin thôi nhưng mà
còn rất nhiều cái để mình có thể thống
kê được Đây là mấy ông thử liệt kê tôi
giờ sự với một thời trang web bán hàng
để tôi thử hỏi các bạn luôn anh có 100
Ông ngồi đây nhưng 100 ông tôi tin 50
ông xe máy rồi thì à
Anh theo các bạn thì một trang web bán
hàng thì sẽ có nên có những cái thống kê
gì
à à
ở một trang web bán hàng tìm ra điểm
danh nào
Ừ
thì nên có những thống kê gì à
ưu điểm danh nào mấy ông ơi
à à
ở kho
hóa đơn
số đơn cái từ số đơn ấy nói rất là chung
chung
Mã số đơn cụ thể số lượng thì sau đơn đã
đạt 2 số đơn như thế nào tất cả đơn
doanh số
cô đơn trong ngày
Ừ Ok để tôi thử liệt kê hết lại những
cái ý các bạn nha à
ờ ờ
nhà hàng trong kho đúng không ạ
Mã số đơn trong ngày
số sản phẩm bán
A
hai.co chỉ Nó tồn kho lắm ạ Dùng từng
tồn kho đi
số đơn trong ngày này lần này
về doanh thu
một số thành viên
lượng truy cập cái có phải rất nhiều
không ạ
ờ ờ
à à
Mã số đơn theo
đã theo thời theo theo mốc thời gian đi
hết bao gồm trong ngày trong tháng trong
năm Quý gì đó hàng bán chạy nhất
khi hạ hàng bán chạy nhất là sẽ gộp
chung vào cái số sản phẩm bán này sẽ bao
gồm là là thống kê sản phẩm bán chạy
không ạ bao gồm bán chạy
Và thậm chí là bán chạy nó sẽ ngược lại
đúng không ạ sẽ là hàng mà cửa không bán
chạy đúng ạ Không bán chạy Tức là chỉ
làm chị chẳng bán được cái cỡ như thế
ờ ờ
xe khách hàng tiềm năng đấu ngoài khách
hàng tiềm năng
tức là ấm chỉ là nếu mà cụ thể hơn sẽ là
số 1 là có thể số đơn khách đã đạt hoặc
cả số tiền khách đã trả Vân Vân đó ngoại
họ xử bạn đến với đặt một đơn rồi đặt
chục triệu không ạ Sẽ Khác
cơ
sở Thống kê như thế Bây giờ để các bạn
liệt kê ra thì nó sẽ tương đối như này
đúng không ạ nghĩa từ một cái thống kê
thôi sẽ
nó sẽ dài hơn sản phẩm theo loại đó cũng
được
mã
sản phẩm theo loại ngày âm Chỉ làm chưa
thể loại này có bao nhiêu sản phẩm thể
loại kia có bao nhiêu sản phẩm cũng được
số mã giảm giá
300 à
Ừ ok Bây giờ mình bắt đầu lượt lượng
luật bớt nhé thứ nhất tạo mình không có
tồn kho với như mình đã nói mình không
dạy các bạn vừa cả lưu lại là là nhập
vậy nhập về bao nhiêu số lượng sản phẩm
đang ở trong database đang là bao nhiêu
nên không có tồn kho bây giờ mình sẽ
lượt bớt dần nhé và đôi nhà không Có
giảm giá không ạ Mình mình chưa dậy các
bạn bây giảm giá giảm giá một cái điều
rất khó khó đấy phải dễ đâu Bạn nghĩ là
nó chỉ xem thêm thử Xóa Nhưng cái để nó
khác mà xem thêm sữa xóa
anh nghe mình chưa Đấy cập ông nào mà ôm
về làm thì cũng được thôi nhưng mà tôi
sẽ bắt bẻ cái đấy ạ
Vì sao nhiều câu ếch queo để do các bạn
phải chuyên sâu về bên em nhiều hơn để
tối ưu cầu Apple Không mình là sữa nặng
và các bạn sẽ phải lạnh Inax các thử nữa
cho nhẹ bụng để mà thống kê để mà tính
toán nữa không phải để tính toán là để
gói wears nó được
ờ ờ
ở đây nhá đầu tiên là Xem lướt qua bảng
phố Đắt mình dậy lưu lại những gì để
chồng kê được Nó chỉ có giá thôi chứ
Chồng giá này bà loại sản phẩm này á đầu
nhà sản xuất chứ không có loại luôn mình
làm không có loại thì chắc là chị thống
kê được à nhà suốt là có bao nhiêu sản
phẩm và giá Thằng nào nhiều nhất giá
thấp nhất hay gì gì đó thôi cũng không
còn giá nhập về giá bán mà chỉ có mỗi
giá bán loạn thế kia thì bảng
ở bảng A đây ra mình có thể thống kê
được cái gì
à thực ra thì như vừa nãy các bạn nói
thì có hệ thống kê được Doanh số trong
ngày này đúng không ạ Bởi vì nó có thời
gian và nó có tổng tiền rồi đấy
chị Xuka Mình có để thống kê thêm giờ
sửa như à khách hàng mua ở đâu nhiều
nhất này đấy bởi vì ở đây à Thật ra bởi
vì mình đang gộp chung vào trong cái cột
là cột địa chỉ và cột này thời ta như
mình từng nói nó cột đa chị thì ra trải
nghiệm đấy ạ Làm cho thống kê này nó khó
hơn nếu mà thống kê muốn cụ thể theo
tỉnh thành phố nào đó là sự thật giữa
quốc gia nào đó là sự tỉnh nào được mua
nhiều nhất để ở mình mình mình mở thêm
chi nhánh ở trong đấy đại khá như thế
thì mình mình nếu mà giờ sự bởi vì hôm
trước mình nhập địa chỉ ở đây nó nhắn
như thế này các bạn có thể trồng cây
được Nếu là nhập địa chỉ rãi hơn là sử
có cả phố cả quận huyện đó thì hạnh tên
thành phố thì mỗi người sẽ nhập thêm một
kìa Anh thành ra là mình rất khó và
thống kê theo lời hứa hẹn trừ khi mình
tách hẳn các cột riêng ra là cột tên phố
này ạ sau đó đi số địa chỉ này xong ngồi
quận huyện này rồi tỉnh thành giống như
nhiều nơi làm thì mình còn toàn hệ thống
kê được xem là đã tỉnh thành phố nào đạt
đơn nhiều nhất mềm các bạn hình dung bọn
đấy do các bạn phải thiết kế ra đây sao
cho mà Để về sau các bạn làm được
em làm được thống kê
chị đã bây giờ để lưu lại thông tin nhắn
làm việc nếu mà các bạn lưu lại hết toàn
bộ trong một cột thì cứ trả nó không
không thống kê được gì và cũng không tìm
kiếm cái gì cả đúng không ạ là sử như
mình từng nói đây các bạn có thể góp hết
toàn bộ Cái này thành chung một cột cột
tên là có thông tin hóa đơn cũng được mà
nếu mà các bạn không làm theo quy tắc
kiểu bỏ qua đa chị thì được cái đấy hoàn
toàn được nó không sai vì nó về các bạn
nó vẫn có thông tin của hóa đơn và vẫn
hiển thị được cho người dùng đúng không
ạ nhưng mà vì sao mày không lọc được là
thằng nào ở đâu đóng ạ này các thứ thứ
đấy
xe khách hàng của mình được hạn chỉ có
tính cơ bản như này thôi cùng lắm là ông
lọc xem là
khách hàng dưới tỉnh Nam hay giới tính
nữ nhiều hơn tại Khánh Như Thế ông ngoại
chết chắc là chẳng có thêm gì cả hai ông
muốn thống kê nữa tên là cái nhà ông ở
tên long nhiều nhất à tên là nhiều nhất
đúng không
Nhưng đại khái méo hiểu gì đâu không ạ
đó là mình có thể áp dụng một vài cái có
thể thống kê được
Mã số đơn theo mốc thời ra làm được này
số sản phẩm bán chạy cũng làm được doanh
thu nó bản chất là tổng tiền trong
khoảng thời gian màu đỏ
cũng trong theo một khoảng thời gian nào
đó đúng không ạ
một số thành viên cũng được này
số thành viên đây mình không theo mốc
thời gian được bởi vì các bạn thấy là
không hề có không hề có cái cột là đăng
ký vào thời gian nào Nếu các bạn muốn
thêm thống kê theo thời gian các bạn
phải thêm cột đấy Ở đấy ông ạ tiếp theo
lượng truy cập lượng truy cập thì thực
ra là như các bạn thấy là mình cũng
không lưu lại cái điều đấy nóng lạnh
Anh thường à Có nhiều bên
nhiều bên thì ở chơi cơ chế là sẽ nhúng
cài Google
em có cái Google Pixel vậy nó sẽ nói
chuyện check in mà nó sẽ kiểm tra luôn
hộ các bạn với việc là có thực sự có bao
nhiêu lượt truy cập phải dùng được thực
sự và bị thực ra là có nhiều người spam
hoặc cả dụng boot Vân hình ra dùng cũng
dùng hằng thứ ba mà thẳng lớn như thế
chắc nó sẽ ổn hơn để mà đánh giá thực sự
có bao nhiêu lượt truy cập cũng được gọi
dùng cũng được bởi vì à
Ừ nó xỉa triệu Hỗ trợ mình phần thôi
Mình vẫn có thể tự làm cái vụ đấy
tiếp theo ở Khang Phạm tiềm năng nhưng
vừa nãy các bạn để cập thì được à Dạ
Mình sẽ nối khách hàng với hóa đơn sau
đó lấy tổng tiền của hóa đơn để ra khách
hàng Khách hàng từ năm đầu nhọn
và hiển thị được vào số đơn đã đặt với
Vân sản phẩm bây giờ sản phẩm kéo hãy mà
thuộc thể loại không ạ
Ừ ok Bây giờ mình sẽ không Không dậy các
bạn với giao diện mình sẽ dạy có bạn về
câu lệnh của axwell để làm từng cái cái
này rồi các bạn tự tự thi cái giao diện
để chuẩn bị ra nhá ông ạ
ở giao diện thì có bạn làm được mà đúng
ạ
ở đầu tiên thì số đơn em mất thời gian
thì ra đâu
Mã số đơn các bạn mình sẽ dùng cao dồi
không ạ select cao
sao trả cũng được
ạ sau đó from order ngày
không ạ
Ừ nếu mà chạy như này chỉ có bạn sẽ thấy
ạ Nó sẽ là lấy gọi là theo thời gian
kiểu chọn đôi lại tham tớ cảm chị à là
không là lấy tất cả Không ạ Không không
que thời gian gì cả Còn nếu các bạn muốn
quay thời gian sẽ where
bộ kịch mẹ đối ngoại nằm trong một
khoảng thời gian nào đó ngoạn thường là
mình sẽ thống kê thời gian theo
ở Thượng Hải trong ngày hôm nay này
Hôm nay này
à à tuần này
ở tháng này
OOO và 5 này chứ ra năm nay năm nay
anh Thắng tháng nay không gọi thì gọi
năm nay lại Ok hoặc trong một khoảng
thời gian nào đó một khoảng thời gian đó
rõ
thì để mà làm được tất cả những cái này
thì các bạn sẽ phải rồi
Ô thế Sao vẫn phải chỉ có bạn một tí giờ
diện
thì mình sẽ có input để mà chọn thời
gian không ạ chọn thời gian này
mình nếu mà mình để trai giống như nhập
bếp như thế này
à à
Ừ
Thì đó chỉ chọn trong một cái mốc thời
gian như thế này không ạ Các bạn thế này
được ra hơi say bởi các bạn sẽ phải chọn
thời gian bắt đầu thời gian kết thúc
Ừ thì nó hợp lý hơn nhưng mà còn nhưng
mà mình đã nói thì ra là nó sẽ nói chú
đây này Hôm nay để ngoại thì sẽ như nào
còn đứa Các bạn chọn như này thì thường
là nó sẽ là trọn trong một ngày hợp lý
hơn mặc định có thể ngày hôm nay đầu
tiên thì các bạn để và mặc định là hôm
nay các bạn sẽ dùng hàm ạ Ở dùng pp balo
nó cái chỗ
nào vậy được không nhỉ
anh không không không phải vậy nào ở
anh tha mà chẳng Tôi không nhớ này lắm
vợ gì Ờ đồ ngon đấy
men đây ngồi tôi nhớ Ừ tao sẽ ngay
Dạ em chào Thầy hiệu phó
ờ ờ thì đây sẽ lấy mặc định ngày hôm nay
Ừ nhưng mà nếu mà các bạn muốn chọn
trong tuần này Thực ra là nó sẽ có cái
input Mình nhớ không lầm
không không không thực nhớ lắm nhưng mà
mình nhớ như có quy kỳ vậy anh có quyết
của món ăn
ở đây Đúng rồi switch
à Còn như này chọn cho tuần này và tương
tự mình có ăn thì phải
Khi Chọn theo tháng
anh không biết có yêu tôi chưa thử vụ đi
cơ
tình yêu không Có người yêu không có ăn
đâu
Anh nghe nè
Ừ
cái vừa rồi Tôi dùng cái này là hàm hàm
để mà hiển thị cho thời gian nhé và theo
quy tắc của nó vẫn là năm nghịch nhanh
tháng rồi em ngày ngay dưới da
ờ ờ không không có năm thì thử cả các
bạn thể cho nhập trai giống như vừa rồi
cũng được
có người dụng không hoặc hoặc là hoặc là
các bạn sẽ chọn như thế này
cho một cái select-options tự tạo ra
thôi và mình sẽ cho TP và for như thế
này mình sẽ cho ra sử thơ ca tôi thường
hay làm đấy tôi thường hay làm nó sẽ là
theo thời gian mà tôi mới tạo ra cái
trang web này đã sửa tôi tạo từ năm
ngoái họ năm kia anh ạ
từ lúc đầu nó cho 20 20 được ạ sau đó đi
đến cái mốc thời gian hiện tại là được
bằng lại một đùi gà này đại là đết tạ
yêu thôi và lại y + + như này à
ấn vào đây tôi sẽ in lại đi acro tôi lại
đi ra
thì đây sẽ hoàn toàn chọn được mốc thời
gian từ 20 20 Cho đến thời gian hiện tại
dùng hanbei để lấy được 5 hiện tạ
Ừ cái này các bạn sẽ không phải sửa cốt
Không Phải Hot cốt là theo kiểu là là
ghi vào trong thẳng trong này là 2022
bởi vì hoàn toàn sang năm thì các bạn
phải vào đây sửa nó lành hay không ai bà
không không ạ lấy thời gian hiện năm
hiện đại mà ngoạn thì các bạn dùng hàng
này còn đây là cái lúc đầu các bạn Thể
khá nhiều trang họ sẽ gán luôn lúc đầu
năm đầu tiên sẽ năm bao nhiêu đúng không
ạ năm đầu tiên này như mình đã nói thì
các bạn nên áp dụng từ chính cái năm ở
trang web này mới có còn không thì nhiều
trang đấy giống như bạn bị giống như hệ
anh thấy thầy Hiệu phó đề xuất Đó là
1970 ạ
1970 nhớ nó còn móc gì chứ
à mà và Thực ra thực là trải nghiệm thế
này thời gian nó không tốt không tốt bởi
vì là các bạn thấy là thường là nó sẽ
chọn những năm gần gần hơn là những 5
kiểu từ xa như hay không ạ thì bài toán
ở đây nên ngược lại một tí họ sẽ lấy từ
như thế này xong rồi ngược lại như này
a197 không ạ Mà nó chưa -
trải nghiệm và sẽ tốt hơn đó như này về
thường là các bạn sẽ quan tâm thống kê
thời gian là trong những năm gần đây chứ
không phải từ năm trong quá khứ Đông ạ
ừ ừ
à à
ở
đây ok rồi lại để hiển thị ra cái để mà
chọn sau đó các bạn chị còn sắp mít nào
lên mình sẽ được vào đây được bạn sẽ ghi
ở trong cái clip tật ở sẽ ra được mà nó
sẽ ra được kết quả thôi
vì vậy số lên 21 thời gian ok rồi thế
cho số sản phẩm bán chạy và không bán
chạy cái Từ khái niệm không bán chạy thì
thì ra nói chuyện ngược lại bán chạy
thôi ông ạ thì đầu tiên là mình sẽ sắp
xếp cái bán chạy không bán chạy thông
qua việc là
A là
ô ô therefore này mình sẽ có cột cột à
mình có quạt et để biết được là sản phẩm
là bán chạy không bán chạy đúng không ạ
Ừ nhưng mà ở đây thật a Thực ra nó sẽ
như thế này là sự ở đây tôi có 8 sản
phẩm ở đâu có 6 sản phẩm lấy thực ra chỉ
có một vài sản phẩm được bán thôi đúng ạ
hiện nhưng mà mình gỡ này phải hiển thị
ra đủ 6 sản phẩm đây và kèm theo ở bên
cạnh
anh có thể hiển thị mã sản phẩm tên sản
phẩm của hình định ra bên cạnh nó sẽ là
số lượng sản phẩm đã bán sau đó thì ông
thường hay sắp xếp là là sắp xếp theo
cái cột số lượng đã bán để để lấy để xem
được sản phẩm bán chạy nhất và sản phẩm
nào bán chạy sau đó ngoại ý
à à
em
viết lệnh để tạo bảng để mà cái sau các
bạn sửa Cốt và gửi code đấy để mà người
khác chạy được luôn Nó sẽ gọi ở file
migration chứ không nên dùng nick nick ở
nhà Thưa click cái kiểu như này xong các
bạn cũng phải ấn vào bên cốt để mà phe
scourge gửi kia nhưng mà ý mình cái
quyết cốt đấy em cái cốt thẳng bằng ngôn
ngữ lập trình chứ không không thừa bằng
axwell nữa
Ừ cái này chắc ở bên liddell mình về sao
mình để cập các bạn lại bạn dễ hình dung
hơn về mai Nathan Lee
Ừ
ok Nói chung là bây giờ có 6 sản phẩm
không ạ Mình sẽ cần ở đây mình sẽ còn
nặng nợ gì mình cần thống kê
thống kê là đầu tiên mình cần lấy mình
hiện thì toàn bộ sản phẩm ra trước đã
mình cậu select này ai đi này
khi nêm này
for roblox
anh như này thôi mà lấy tất cả thông tin
của ID và nêm và sản phẩm không ạ tiếp
theo nữa đó là mình sẽ cân bà lấy số
lượng của số lượng và thống kê số lượng
không ạ một là các bạn dùng à Seung Ri
ta sẽ kéo saly luôn lồng salad ở ngay
đây và lồng xe lách cũng được hay là các
bạn ạ
thứ hai các bạn dùng cho và
gà chọi ở đây ra ở đây rồi ta mình sẽ
nếu mà các bạn dùng roi và thực à mạnh
mẽ QR các bạn nên dùng cho vì nó tối ưu
truy vấn hơn nó nhẹ hơn do việc có bạn
dùng Safari I
a nhớ các bạn dùng cho ở đây Các bạn nên
dùng led trôi chứ không phải nên dùng in
Android vì tay mình sẽ thử chị bạn Tại
sao đầu tiên mình dùng in cho trước đi
baldr force này on orders đắt chấm ID
bằng boodog chở mai đi em ạ
Ừ nếu bạn chạy như này bạn sẽ thấy là nó
sẽ hiển thị ra mỗi hai sản phẩm thôi mà
còn lặp lại còn bị lặp lại
Ừ đúng ạ
Mình lỡ ân ái
à à
em mình hơi khó chịu đấy Cái cái câu
truy vấn này nó không để hai địa chị
thành an của phim mấy ông ấn quay lại
lắm chỉ muốn khôi phục lại khâu cũ được
ra nói mất Hôm sau mình mình kỹ lại nhé
Thì mình đi lại
Có
ai đi này lên này from code này
Ừ thì à
ạ Bây giờ mình sẽ dùng read your
order đó
see more on the fourth chấm proxy đi
bằng golf
Xin chào Mai đi nha Chẳng ạ
Ừ nếu bạn chạy như thế này thì bạn sẽ
thấy là nó sẽ hiển thị tất cả sản phẩm ở
đây
Ừ nhưng mà sản phẩm 7 và 8 vẫn đang bị
lặp lại vì nó vẫn ông dùng do mà nó là
tại hai phát Thế là các bạn thể dùng
Goodbye để mà nhóm máu lại để tránh việc
lặp lại như thế này sẽ giúp anh thường
mình sẽ giúp anh theo ID của sản phẩm
của tiếng nói duy nhất sẽ không lặp lại
nó chạy này
ở đó sẽ không lặp lại nữa và bây giờ nếu
các bạn chỉnh các bạn muốn thống kê là
các bạn sẽ tính tổng của cái con Titi đã
để biết được đã bán bao nhiêu
ở đài mình sẽ ra
anh
ở đây là xăm con Ti Ti
bài hát
ờ ờ
quantity sails Hạ
à à
ô tội chẳng biết câu này nên đặt như nào
đại khá như thế đã bán đúng không
Ừ có gì xảy ra như này các bạn thể cho
mặc định cái này nếu mà ít luôn có cái
hàm lại ít luôn à
Ừ thì sẽ cho không nhé
ca nhạc Nhớ có hạt mít luôn mà Em hãy
tsmu nhỉ It's known
khi chờ ít lùn mai que à
không có mà
Chỉ có mày ạ
Ừ
đúng rồi ạ Em phải để làm sao tôi xin
lỗi tôi xuống
khi đó nó sẽ ra không nhưng mà cái này
nó sẽ bị cái đó là
Ừ thứ nhất là cái này về cơ bản mới Ông
thấy ổn rồi theo kiểu là ok Nó hiển thị
ra được nói đi là được số xăng còn đã
bán theo từng sản phẩm đó ông ạ
Ừ nhưng mà cái điều tôi muốn nói đấy Đó
là cái này thật ra không phải số sản
phẩm đã bán và số dân phẩm đã được đặt
con số sản phẩm đã bán ra mình sẽ phải
nối mạng oder nữa mình lại phải lép do
mạng order nữa đây lấy được là và mình
sẽ queo status của order là là bằng một
ở đâu = = Mấy nhà có đến mình quý ông
mùng mấy nhỉ Không còn mới đặt một là
đặt được đặt rồi thì vậy đấy ra xử như
thế thì sẽ ghép do tiếp này order
là con ô tô chấm ID bằng on the lorax
chấm ordered ạ
sau đó thì mình sẽ que
order chấm Sắp chết bằng một phát sướng
ngay
ở trận này
bài hát
ai ngờ con máy kéo mình chết Đợi đến
được tắt đi mở lại sẽ
à à
ừ ừ
anh mãi axetilen ID Ok trả lại
ở cột ID nó bị lặp lại rồi vì a trong
cho Mảo đỡ có một ai đi mình sẽ ghi rõ
là cô đắp chấm Mai đi này và qua đắp
chấm nên cho chắc
vì
vậy trong trường hợp này mấy ông thấy nó
bị sai tại sao bị sai nếu béo để ý kĩ
Tuy ở mình có dùng nét vôi để mà việc là
mình không bị mình lép trôi thì tức à
Cái phốt này nó không phụ thuộc hoàn
toàn ở mordor Đông ạ nhưng mà các bạn
thấy là bởi vì mình queo status cho đời
sau tước bằng bằng một ngân hàng ra là
là bắt buộc phải có oder thì mới mới
chạy đúng ạ Ở đây các bạn có thể thêm
một cái mẹo nữa đó là các bạn sẽ to
order
anh ở đây ở đây tôi sẽ tặng xóa cái này
đi à
Ừ để cho mày ông dễ hiểu hơn tôi sẽ ạ
ở tạm copy cái này xa để xa bỏ lúc bay
đi để mày ông dễ hình dung hơn toilet
cho ngay mình sẽ hình dung được hơn đây
kệ ID của cô đắt ở đây nhá
Ê mấy thằng này được đẩy lên đầu những
kệ không có tâm đi bây sản phẩm iPhone
12 này toàn bộ những thông tin bên này
để là nôn hết này bởi vì rõ là nó làm gì
có đơn đâu đó ngoại thì méo có thể chơi
trò lách như thế này đó là Order chấm sa
tế ớt itneun cũng được hoặc nhỏ thường
là để ở chắc cú hơn thì sẽ là Order cây
chính tôi thường ấy bảo chính cái cái
cái để mà dùng cho ấy nó là nun gà cho
củ nhất sẽ thể order cho median ol họ
order code sấm ordered luôn cũng được
Sữa mẹ là một trong hai này như thế này
thì nó sẽ ra được
Ồ thông tin nha Đó Ngoại ok Bây giờ mình
dùng roi để mà thống kê nhà mình có thể
ghi lại câu lệnh này bằng một cách khác
Ừ tôi thường ấy thích cách khác này cho
dù Thực ra nó bị
vì nó có thể nó có thể dễ hiểu hơn có
thể để đối với tôi nó không biết mấy ông
đến nhưng mà nhưng mà kể tôi không quên
Mấy ông thường khá vô cái đấy vì tôi đã
nói mày quen nó tối bên your chứ phải
Safari Tôi sẽ thử viết bằng sắc với
người ông sẽ thấy nó sẽ dễ hơn so với
việc làm dài dòng ngay đây tôi sẽ dùng
Shayk vẫn là sẽ lách thôi xăm nóng ạ con
đi thi nhưng thương
quá đi tí này lấy từ bảng nào đây
khi enter a nhìn rất rõ này
à À ý anh ý anh là đoạn en ở đâu
em em em em lỡ xóa sư về câu chưa Vẫn
chưa
anh đấy em ạ
Anh
vừa gọi E ở đâu nhỉ
à à
a
form order form này
nhà mình có thể quay ngay đây này order
for đắp chấm phố Decade Bằng chính cái
code Mẹ gửi đến này chấm ID để lấy được
cái con Ti Ti của cái oder bộ lắp và cái
này không còn newbi nữa vì về cơ bản thì
cái này đến theo từng sản phẩm nếu có
rồi thử chạy thử trong mấy ông xe luôn
chú chó đứng như cái này nó bị quá dài
nên thành ra là
Ừ chắc á con sâu à Như có con xô Vậy để
xem nhẹ
cho mình nhớ ở thoại có một cái lưu lại
câu truy vấn ở đâu đấy
anh ở đây đấy
anh không không không không có
anh ở đây đây Ok Ok
à à
á nhon Mình mình nhớ có con sâu bao
nhiêu Mình ở ít dùng ví dụ
Ừ ông anh bảo ở lạc trôi đoạn này có
thêm en ở đâu nhỉ
à Mình mình dùng cái tôm khác thì nó
thường anh Hiển thị cũng con sông ai ở
vừa ấy nó hiển thị ra luôn Đấy nó không
kiểu check bạn như này thì mình đi cái
đấy hôn
chú ý anh là em ở ngay bạn này đúng
không
em thấy quen ở đây mình sẽ ngay đây à
anh đi làm à
ừ ừ
à à
Ừ cái để tạo đây đã nhé Đợi Anh ấy trả
lời à
anh Kể tóm tắt lại đi này
Ê mấy ông thấy à thực ra cái này nó bị
dài đoạn này nhìn thấy áp ở đây là quan
đi
sale không ạ Ừ nhưng mà tương tự giống
như nãy nói là thật là mình sẽ phải cho
anh nữa đâu ạ trong trường hợp này mình
thể inner cho luôn vì bản chất là mình
cần đến Thực ra cái đoạn này nó không
ảnh cái này cho này không ảnh hưởng thêm
câu lắp các bạn thấy ở đây vẫn phải luôn
thoải mái vẫn thị force là bình thường
em vẫn dùng cho rồi enjoyed Được on
order này chân ai đi bằng order doc.org
đi này và mình hoàn toàn quay ở đây luôn
được Em
Order chấm status bằng một nhà ở đâu này
ở đó Nó xảy ra các bạn thấy ạ
Tôi thích Hồi đấy tôi bị nghiện Seung Gi
ờ
Ê hồi nãy tự nhiện Sapa đi vì nó kiểu
kiểu nó viết nó sẽ đỡ phải natwara cho
một đống như thế này nhà Đương nhiên chị
nhất cho như này nó lại nhẹ hơn đấy nhá
nó nhẹ và xử lý nhanh hơn do cái này mấy
cái này nó duyệt từng cứ mỗi lần với một
thành phố đắt nó lại gọi lại đến hàng
oder paulus của và order để để lấy thông
tin có bao nhiêu cô đắp nó sẽ chạy bẫy
như vòng lập cái này em bé không thấy nó
nặng như thế nào con khi mà Các bạn góp
hết lại rồi Các bạn mình mới lấy nó sẽ
bị nó sẽ nhẹ hơn rất nhiều nhà nên là
tôi khi mà làm thống kê được cả tôi
không khuyên mấy ông làm như hay là sự
có bao nhiêu sản phẩm nó bấy nhiêu lần
cái truy vấn như này thì mấy ông sẽ thấy
nó ạ giữa nặng không ạ Đây à
ở nhà Tôi đang đi tôi đang ghi cho mấy
ông ấy mấy ông thấy nó cũng có 2 cách để
ghi thôi Cái này tương tự ở mấy ông có
thể cho ít luôn ở đây được đội đây là
Thêm số 0 vào đây nữa thì nó sẽ không
thôi
xin lỗi à
xin lỗi này không tắt đi đấy nek to
dismiss không được mà
cho tao xem nhé
thì tại sao để đổi nha Xem lại nha luôn
đấy con tefal
Ừ anh âm nhạc phải ít luôn cho này xin
lỗi xin lỗi xin lỗi nó sai cái này vẫn
đóng mở ngoặc này nó ngoác này vậy không
này
Em đâu rồi
ờ ờ
ô tô rồi đó thì đây là vừa rồi mình làm
mình chỉ các bạn thống kê số số sản phẩm
bán được mà đỡ nhiên các bạn hoàn toàn
có thể là cả hai cách này các bạn hoàn
toàn thể order bay theo cái cột này để
lấy được order
bye này và PC thì sẽ là lấy lấy ra được
sản phẩm bán chạy nhất nhưng ngoài ra
còn thêm cái hay nữa thôi chị mấy ông đó
là mấy ông ngoài việc là ok sản phẩm bán
chạy nhất này thì mấy ông sẽ nghĩ là ok
ngược lại đúng không ạ sẵn bà sẽ là ra
sản phẩm không bán chạy không ạ Không
cái này thì ra đó vẫn chưa hẳn đã đúng
lắm để tôi gợi ý thêm mì ông đó là mấy
ông phải sắp xếp theo những sản phẩm đã
nhập là sử đây rõ là B sản phẩm nhập lâu
hơn sản phẩm này không ạ thì về cơ bản
thì treo thời gian thì rõ ràng là thằng
ngày mới hàng không bán chạy nhất chứ
thế này đúng ạ mày không méo gì tôi
không ạ Đấy thì tôi phải cho phải lên
trước tới 8 chỉ mình sắp xếp theo cột
này và khi sắp xếp theo của Wendy sale
rồi Nếu mà khi cột mày bằng nhau thì
mình sẽ Vậy sắp sẽ theo cả May mà kể mãi
tự động tăng lên thành ra là kiểu cái
xanh nằm mà nhập Nó kiểu cổ nó bé hơn
rất cám chị nó mới á nó lâu hơn so với
thằng này xài sẽ mới hơn không ạ Đấy
mình sẽ phải order Bike theo hai cụt thì
mình sẽ ra ai đi nữa cô đắp
chả mai đi vào đây sẽ là 2C thời gian
chị ạ
Ừ Đấy Thế này mới gọi là không Bạn trạng
nhất
Ừ nó cũng vậy không ạ ạ
a tiếp theo doanh thu thì mất thời gian
để chúng ta còn dễ hơn cái cái vừa nãy
nói chỉ đơn giản là tính tổng đúng ạ xem
một mốc thời gian nào đó
cho doanh thu được không là Thu về chứ
không phải doanh số gì vậy lỗ lãi đúng
không
số trường hợp nó là ID thay vì để tự
động tăng như thế này thì thì mình nên
thêm cột nó ngọn mình thêm cột à khi mà
kiểu nhập vào thì mình sẽ thêm cột cột ở
với tất cả ạ Nó cột khi mà mình
in rất nó ra
Ừ nhưng mà ra đây mày không dậy được các
bạn đến cái bước là là kiểu nhập kho hay
là tồn kho gì cả chị nhập mức tương đối
thôi Đây là cái này thì ra là nó đủ để
mà thống kê một tí rồi
anh em chưa dậy các bạn mà yêu ai đi
không đi thường cho bên liên quan đến
khát ta bây hơn là khi tách bây ra hay
nhiều bây khác nhau thì cái số tự động
Đăng nó có thể trùng Giang đã ra tay kia
đây mình sẽ phân biệt nhau qua một cái
mã nó không bị chung nhưng mà không phải
tự động thanh nữa ừ ừ
khi doanh thu theo mốc thời gian này
mình có đề cập thì sẽ là
ở
bên order đóng mình sẽ có
thì mình sẽ chỉ cần xăm nó thôi là lấy
được thôi ông ạ khá dễ
thì mình sẽ là select some
Total Price
for order đúng ạ
À thì ra thế này ra rồi còn theo mốc
thời gian nhưng mình vừa nãy nói với thì
ạ Các bạn lấy thời gian từ đăng nhập lên
mình sẽ mình sẽ que không ạ Mình sẽ que
theo
a waiter cột ở
ở quế thật đúng rồi con thêm wak cả sau
tất bằng bằng mụn nữa
quê status bằng 10 ạ
Mình chỉ thống kê những đơn đã đặt đúng
không ạ những đơn ở đâu những đơn đã
duyệt chứ còn những đơn đã đạt thì nó
Đạt láo thì kệ thôi ông ạ
một số thành viên thì thực ra nó là
select cao customer thôi ông ạ Cái này
phá dễ này
số lượng truy cập từ những mình nói là
không không làm được trên lưu lại khách
hàng tiềm năng này Thực ra là mình sẽ
roi bảng nóng ạ Cái đoạn này nhưng mình
nói được cao dùng subcribe hỏi cho gọn
được mình sẽ là sếp
Ừ mình vẫn là ai đi này
À thì ra là không cần hình thị cơ sở mới
đi nữa mà mình hiển thị cái tên rồi trả
cũng được form cơ sở mờ trước đi cho tỷ
lệ toàn bộ tên ông ạ sau đó thì mình sẽ
ghép do nếu mình nói phải dùng lap doi
vì chưa chắc là khách khách đăng ký vui
như chưa đặt sản phẩm nào thì không nhìn
thị ra rồi nó không hay mình cứ kệ đi
tất cả khách hàng nhưng mà mình sẽ hiển
thị ra khách đã ban đã đặt những nào
không ạ
I love all audio on all their personal
đi
customer My em ạ
ạ sau đó thì thế ra các bạn có thể hiển
thị ra ở đây hoặc không tùy
thị ra đây là xăm Total Price này
hát
chụp em ạ
là đã thanh toán bao nhiêu này
ấn vào đây mình sẽ que order
gì chấm status bằng à
ở vòng 1 to order
3.2
a Custom ID họ gái đi Tui It's known
chồng như vừa nãy anh nói bởi vì trong
trường hợp mà order có này không không
không có là mình sẽ order
A Goodbye
customer.io sắc
vì nếu mà không không rút bay đầy mình
thử không lúc bay cho các bạn xem nhé
ở bảng xếp hạng lỗi như này luôn đấy thứ
ra cái tắt cái này tắc kè đi được
em có thể vào cái này để tắt đi
em làm gì là
bỏ có nền xe lách những cái cột không
nằm trong Goodbye vấn đề ra đi được
Ừ nhưng mà khi tắt đi nó sẽ bị hiển thị
sai thông tin chắc chắn nó thế bởi vì nó
sẽ hiển thị ra tổng tiền của tất cả các
đơn thôi chứ không phải theo từng người
người dùng nữa
anh ở đây Ở đây đang có mỗi một người có
sờ
Em xem mình đúng không
tự hào đồng hồ có mỗi một khách hàng đã
xử lý sớm thêm một khách hàng nữa thì
chắc chắn nó chưa đạt đơn ông ạ à
à à
Ừ chắc nghe được rồi
cho anh em nhé
a hack shop luôn hai ông à ok
à à
anh có hai bạn
Ừ thì các bạn có thể thêm cái order bay
ở đây ô ô their bay chim cánh cụt
totopaz này và DC sẽ giảm dần đúng không
thế này để lấy được khách hàng tiềm năng
Mã số đơn cách đã trả nó cũng tương tự
mình có thể cao đây cao có đồ chấm mai
đi học customer ID cũng được Tại sao
không phải là cao sao Bởi vì nếu cao sao
nó sẽ khác để tôi sẽ cho hai ví dụ cho
mấy ông
có xào nó sẽ đến không theo việc còn
luôn hay không Hãy nhìn nay chẳng hạn
đi đái rõ ràng và nếu K sao nó sẽ luôn
là một bởi vì có một bản ghi em à ạ Còn
đây ở sẽ kiểm tra xem mà có đơn có đơn
thì nó mới đến đấy các bạn sẽ phải cao
đúng cột thì nó chuẩn hơn
ở đó đó là khách hàng tiềm năng có sản
phẩm theo hãy chỉ ra các bạn sẽ cũng
tương tự là các bạn sẽ
chị sẽ trâu chọi với cái bảng My fossil
là cao là lấy được thôi đó đó về thống
kê
cho bộ mai giải phết nhỉ Tôi bắt đầu khả
năng dần rồi
ờ ờ
thứ hai để buổi sau đi buổi sau mình sẽ
dạy các bạn về à bình luận nhỉ
em buổi sau mình dậy các bạn Nốt rồi cái
bình luận đề ông ạ
ừ ừ
các bạn còn đầu tiên thì các bạn có tham
ăn gì Biến thống kê thì ông ạ Còn buổi
sau tôi sẽ dậy mấy ông nợ tại sao buổi
sau đi các bạn ông về dùng ra Switch để
mà bình luận rồi hiển thị luôn cả bình
luận ngay ngay lập tức rồi đấy chứ không
phải là phải loạn lại trang mới hiển thị
ra được bình luận
Ừ nếu như mình vẫn sẽ đẩy cái bình luận
lên bằng bằng form đẩy lên
a di tinh tình đánh giá đúng không Ok
mình sẽ nốt lại buổi sao cả
tất cả dưới tinh nó cả đánh giá và cả
bình luận nhé
à à
ở đài mình lại
e
+ đánh giá sao chẳng hạn rating không ạ
ạ
à à
ờ ờ
Ừ ừ đúng rồi mình xin phép chia sẻ nốt
cài hai cái Soft này cho nhanh này cái
mình thấy khá hay chia sẻ các bạn ký để
các bạn thấy nó ảo như thế nào
Em gọi thử xem nhé
Anh ở nay lãi phải phóng to lên được
tr1
cài đặt Bluetooth
đ.to
anh
ấy giờ đây là bộ đội
a
[âm nhạc]
Christmas special that Mr first name
against Some people wait
here their work with this is one of
protection and many more King's raid
Mode this on the finest Atletico Unicode
with lots of people current and
beautiful bays in its dịch Center is
accompanied for android with Unicode can
afford to Stand By Me If you're nothing
compares
butsakorn tour live in yourself with
compassion street gonna start you
received from users the content no
nesticle missile Places which directly
to you can use the Beautiful Woman is
made you can choose any file lights
Galaxy r d r kaycee allkpop Awards and
consistent and stick with enough I
Ê mấy ông thấy vừa rồi làm một cái của
chính giờ đây là bộ cài đặt tới đâu Cái
này đây Horse em đi rồi lao động sẽ này
thì hồi nữa vì bí của
chỉ có một thứ rất khó chịu không ạ
kể cái này là kiểu đó rủ hai cái giống
hệt nhau Nhưng mà thực ra là không không
không được mail nhưng cái này không phải
là mỗi ra Swift mà nó ngôn ngữ chung tất
cả ngôn ngữ khác đó là gì đó là với cái
kiểu unicas như này nhìn trông có vẻ
giống hệt nhau
nhưng mà thật ra Nó là một cái thì nó là
đăng ký tự luôn trong bảng chữ cái có
thật thì nó lại em gấu một cái lại E rồi
thêm dấu thật thành và x2 ra nói mấy
Latinh không ạ Nếu mà giận Cắt nghĩa nó
ra lại xảy ra như này hoặc được
kim.me là sẽ lấy cái lúc đấy không như
lại không Cái Hàn để mà thường người ta
sẽ dùng tại Hà mẹ con bớt nó ra
đăng ký để mở ra thành hết chữ cái thật
thì những cái chữ mà được ghét bưởi ghép
bởi ký tự nó sẽ tách ra như này à ở đấy
có phải mỗi ra Speed Âu hỗ trợ chữa tôi
bị dính ở bên ra rồi và Chắc cái bệnh
dính
Chúng tôi khuyến mấy ông như thế này tôi
từng bị dính lấy tổ mò mất thời gian và
nhiều người từng bị mòn em mất thời gian
đấy mà thêm một cái nữa nhé một cái nữa
cũng cũng cũng vãi chưởng lắm này
I just like me a story on a different
World
a.to menu help us
a Death Metal I am I forget about to
make you have occurred in The Winner Is
Zero whit Pikachu static attention and
strategies Google When is the easy way
It Hurts you tell me don't lie to the
punch and the late because Death is your
expected confused with either Trish
summerville Achilles heel Balm Use this
feature that enables you to unicard hay
Wedding present simple Touch with
glowlight now You can see Thái lại
Nautilus esata heritable you Dragon Hill
and execute and the world and articles
about their papers on ostrich problem
World
Ừ
cái này thì nếu mà mấy bạn để vừa rồi
nữa thì còn bị thêm một quả đó là cho
cho ký tự mà đi tượng nhiều bé là lý do
nhiều ông cả là tên được là tên cậu Dạ
không có gì ở trên Facebook được đúng
không thể copy được cái tên là luôn Vì
nó là ký tự Không khoảng trắng đó ngoại
à
mà hình như bây giờ vẫn bị dịch 10 thằng
trong Facebook nó chơi kiểu nói cao nên
nó không có ràng buộc kiểm tra gì cả nó
không ai đấy ở miền Bắc em được cái nó
chỉ cần kiểm tra có ký tự thôi
à à
Ừ thế là thằng vé Cốt nó đang quảng cáo
Thêm cái vụ tình năng của nó là kiểm tra
xem mình trong cốt nó Cậu sinh ký tượng
này không phải loại bỏ đi cái mấy ông
Nếu mày nếu không tái máy mài ông không
có Cốc trên mạng vì và thừa Cốt trên
mạng code trên special lâu chắc là nó
không áp dụng với cho mày đâu nếu mà có
phải ông và muốn chê ông kiểu thì nó bên
vai đấy có bị lỗi ở Ngạn nhập một đông
ký tự hoặc trắng này vào tên của nó biến
kí tự đặc biệt là Nhạn thì sẽ làm được
nên là mẹ cũng phải kiểm tra và kiểm tra
về giao một cốt của mình có vấn đề gì đó
thì có kìa mẹ không phải cân nhắc việc
mở cái mở cái cái kiểm tra khoảng trắng
này lên xem có tính tự nhiên là thừa có
khoảng còn trắng nhưng mà đợi kiểu
0-zero ở đây không hiển thị ra không ạ
vì không khỏa trắng cho vẫn là một ký tự
không ạ
Ừ Ok nói cho bộ hôm nay mình dậy là chia
sẻ có thể tương đối nhỉ các bạn có thắc
mắc gì thì bình luận sau nha
bữa mày tra tạm kết thúc rồi đấy thôi
Dạ em chào thấy hiệu Thọ hệ phó nay dự
giờ em sợ quá à
à à
cho AD có bạn hỏi nhanh như vụ là chia
sẻ Cẩm shop từng bị chán cốt theo mình
từng trả lời có ngày rồi à
ừ ừ
có động lực để mặc Cốt lại thì sẽ dẫn ạ
Không phải về mỗi cốc ngoài về mọi thứ
khám chị ạ Bạn sẽ bạn sẽ cần là tự tự ra
cho mình nó nào giống như là mình từng
tỏ tình của mình bại Đã Ngạn áo kiểu
tiểu thất bại ram sẽ dễ làm thôi mình sẽ
lên cẩu thứ nhất là phải làm gì đó Tạm
quên rồi đi đã Cứ cố nghĩ là nó lại càng
cay thứ hai là
các bạn sẽ nên khi họ bắt đầu lại thì
các bạn nên bắt đầu lại bằng cái canh
tiếp cận dễ trước đã Ừ chứ không nên bắt
đầu lại lại làm lại nhảy vào những cái
khó đấy nhỉ người lại tán cái đứa không
nhưng mà mình đã từng thất bại thì anh
nghe là nó sẽ càng khiến mình có thể bị
chậm chậm hơn không ạ
thì các bạn sẽ phải kiểu
quên nó đi này
ở trong ngành Công nghệ thông tin này là
không nên cố quá thì các bạn đang bị
căng thẳng đang không Cốt được bạn cứ
nghỉ ngơi các bạn có giải trí cho nó lúc
sau lại tập trung lại không sao cả đều
ngoạn đấy thế thôi nước khuyên mình thế
gì hả ông anh Thế ông anh ông anh thế
Không khuyên được người khác đâu không
ai Khuyên người khác nhìn lại và cái khó
để mà lại ngã à
Ê chắc rồi
Ồ không Tôi bảo mấy ông cố quên đâu Tôi
bảo mày ông làm việc khác thôi Tôi không
bảo mấy ông cố quên Nếu càng nghĩ càng
cố càng cố nghĩ thì chắc chắn càng cũng
nhớ Với cả mẹ ông cứ nghĩ là ông càng
Hằng nó sâu trong đầu thì mày không sẽ
nhớ tôi bảo béo làm việc khác thôi Làm
cái khác mà vẫn nhờ đến nó thì vẫn kệ đi
ý ra ông vẫn đang làm việc khác ngồi
kiểu gì cũng sẽ quên nó nào giống như
kiểu ông cố tập trung để ngủ thì ông sẽ
không ngủ được con khi mà ông cứ nằm ông
kiểu
em nằm nhắm mắt thôi Được kiểu thế không
nghĩ gì cả thì hôm sẽ tự động ngủ thấy
thôi
Ê mày cũng chưa gặp trường hợp đấy nếu
anh càng cố ngủ mà ông càng không ngủ
được bởi vì nó vẫn đang nghĩ không ạ
những câu nói của anh về cái thiên tài
làm em nhớ về cái vụ
thiên tài với thằng điên là là một
khoảng cách rất gần
Ừ nếu mà nếu mà anh mà không chứng minh
được mình đúng cái gì anh sẽ thằng điên
nó mắt này khác còn đấy anh chứng minh
được mình đúng còn mọi người sai anh sẽ
thành thiên tài
Ừ Ok thôi bội mày tạm kết thúc vào đây
thôi
ờ ờ
Ừ có gì thì mình sẽ trả lời Mọi thắc mắc
sau nha
ừ ừ